be amazing if i could come together with
you and aledawa for example and i could
simply ask alidawah about his beliefs
and he could ask me about mine we could
talk to each other you can tell us what
you think
you can share your beliefs we don't need
to fight all that we need is to sit
together and have an
honest exchange of opinions and ideas
beliefs and feelings
people would love to see that happen you
can then observe what really believes in
i can see through you i see through your
eyes i keep oh man it's it you're the
shaytan speaking but you know what we're
gonna let you talk let's see what else
you got
wrong path buddy and i really really
really feel like you could be going the
right path if you just stop
being a little weenie man thank you you
are a little weenie buff you're a phony
you're a phony yes bob you're a phony
this journey this road that i travel on
it all seems crazy over the years i
picked up thousands of tiger lungs
inspired by my story from a juvenile
when my clothes had holes in them and my
afro is picky
to the nighties moschino and versace
no laces in her cheeks new millennium
assalamu alaikum welcome to better care
two brothers and sisters and dear
friends hope you guys are wearing
trouble
okay so bro and sisters i'm going to be
reacting to a video that adam is
reacting to
yeah now brothers and sisters
alhamdulillah recently you know we spoke
about adam hamdulillah we had some
really positive changes
we spoke to him we learned from each
other alhamdulillah we've changed he's
changed
alhamdulillah so um brothers and sisters
excuse me not quran here don't worry go
go anyways yeah so brother sisters now
when a group of the muslim the
means if the muslims come together
surely the enemies of allah are going to
be uncomfortable they're going to lose
some sleep
maybe lose some weight maybe lose some
brain cells
why because they are suffering and this
was made very evident
when adam saleh actually spotted this he
said hold on a second these ex-muslims
are getting happy and they're trying to
cause tension between me and brother ali
yeah alhamdulillah that was so
refreshing to hear that because he saw
right through them
now what's happening is though i'm
observing this
ex-muslim community most of them are
fake by the way muslim never a muslim in
the first place
they left something they never belong to
and subhanallah
and subhanallah i'm seeing these guys
they have an unrest this very guy adam
saw is reacting to it's as if he woke up
in the middle of the night disturbed
you know and he had to do a video and
let's see what that video is
and let's see how adam saleh responds
because he's trying to give a shock
effect to adam saleh like there's
certain things that me and mohammad
hijab
and brother imran we believe that adam
salad doesn't know
if he knows he'll be like no let's
listen to this guy his name is
short for you know don't be a let's
watch it i'm giving me a message hi
everyone and welcome this is the
apostate prophet i hope you're having a
great day
just want to put a quick message out
there today i want to send out a message
to adam saleh a
youtube vlogger and entertainer who is
very popular among younger cultural
muslims
he recently had a beef with aledawa a
youtube vlogger and comedian
oh uh sorry muslim apologist was also
already from there like he sounds like a
hater of people who give that out of
islam like i really i can see it
i can throw you i see through your eyes
i can oh man i said you're the shaytan
i'm speaking but you know what we're
going to do
i can't disagree with that yet adam's
he's right through you boy
boy boy boy
right for you you punk
let's carry on what else you got to say
very popular among younger religious
muslims who somehow managed to
take him seriously i don't really care
about their beef i have no idea what it
is about but after making peace with
aledawa adam sally published a video
in which he featured one of my tweets
and talked about ex-muslims including
introverted smiles
he expressed how he would like to talk
to ex-muslims and exchange thoughts with
them his idea is that ex-muslims try to
cause unrest and
separation between muslims and that they
try to damage islam he's not entirely
wrong about the latter i have to admit
yeah sorry i think adam saleh himself is
not a bad person
it looks like he has a good heart i
don't think he wants to harm anybody
although he does depict the ex-muslim as
the devil with horns
but i would say that is expected it's
fairly normal it's actually even
exactly do you see adam saying oh no no
i'm so sorry
no and adam's saying yes
you are shaytan you know why because you
want
problems between us too and because now
you've seen the unity upon the quran and
the sunnah
yes you've seen that the brothers have
come together against
enemies like you yeah intellectually
intellectually yeah
okay that's why you're bothered you're
hurt you hurt so much that look how your
eyes are popping you woke up flipping
three in the morning
you're disturbed by that you're
disturbed
get disturbed die in your age innocent
because as a muslim you learn that you
cannot trust the world you cannot trust
others the disbelievers are there to
deceive you and to harm you and it is
you the muslims against
everybody else so what would you then
expect to think about people who left
your religion and to talk about it and
against it
but here is my message to adam sally
adam i believe that you are genuinely a
good person
and i'm not saying this to trick you or
to deceive you that's nonsense i'm just
a normal human i'm a person just like
you
the only difference that we are having
here is that i no longer believe in a
religion that you
want to hold on to despite the fact that
you are maybe not the best muslim out
there which is quite understandable by
the way when i was a muslim i kind of
judged people like you for not following
their creator properly if my mom was
here she would seriously be like
simply a very unrealistic expectation
because most people will never
follow their creator properly and
especially not in the way that islam
demands them to the problem adam listen
carefully what he says there yeah
he says most people cannot follow their
religion perfectly because
you know it's hard basically yeah
brothers and sisters
the comparison between adam and this guy
yeah
okay he's claiming that he was before
like adam apparently yeah okay
there is a mountain of difference
between you and adam because you're a
little weakling let me tell you why
don't call this edward listen carefully
guys this is so profound
so profound yeah brothers and sisters
this little boy this little kid yeah i'm
going to say something and i'm going to
tell you why
he is a weak ones little ones
untrained ones college students
boy let me tell you why brothers and
sisters why is he a boy
because he left islam apparently i don't
believe that yeah
let's suppose argument's sake here he
left islam why because of
things that he couldn't do and his
friend and most them if you talk to them
oh ramadan was too it's too hard
drinking not drinking alcohol
okay uh staying away from girls or doing
this or doing that is so hard
and you left islam now we are for for
sure and since
but brother adam is well look look
brother adam has made mistakes as well
handle his publicly repented yeah and
he's
i'm gonna mail next year the difference
between
you your little punk your little puss
your little boy
and between you and adam is what adam
never abandoned his religion because of
his shortcomings
that is a believer his wrong his
wrongdoings
disturbed him so much so that he looked
for solutions he didn't like it
and a sign of repentance is that one has
regret regrets tries to stop it and not
try not to go back to it however you you
little weakling little boy
what did you do apparently and your
friends or whoever
oh i left this damn because it was too
hard that's why there is a mountain of
difference between you and adam
adam is not someone who just turns his
back to his religion he understands
he tries to better himself because allah
is the most merciful what did you do you
turned your back
against your religion which i don't
believe you ever was a muslim in the
first place anyways
but your friends and most ex-muslims
what do they do oh that doesn't make
sense to me or didn't make sense to me
oh that was hard
this was this desires subhanallah got
the better of you you're a weakling
don't project your weak little boy
on adam don't project yourself an adam
because you're a little
weak little boy and now you're saying
adam yeah we know
it's hard for you you know constantly
not to do things anymore but
the difference between you and him are
mountains
because he's somebody acknowledges sins
and repents and carries on
striving and never giving up in the
mercy of his lord and
you little boy are going to be if you
don't repent amongst those
under their judgment standing regretting
and you know on the deja they're going
to be a group of people
the smiling sinners who were they they
were people
who sent but repented and allah admitted
them to jannah
not like you we ask allah to guide you
anyways let's carry on let's carry on i
don't think you are aware of what islam
really teaches
and you are not aware of what the people
that you made peace with and came
together and had fun with
actually believe it ya allah please
guide this ex-muslim
please guide him to the right path
because he's lost he he's i'm afraid
i'm afraid like he actually seems like a
genuine guy but honestly i feel like
that he's just really really lost just
like how i just lost brain cells right
now you just oh
you would not want to believe that
certain people should be massacred
executed
for making simple life choices over
their beliefs whereas
do believe in such things oh my god look
there's such bad
people look muhammad ali they do
believe every muslim is the same thing
brother you're the one that's making it
seem like it's crazy like obviously in
the olden days is much much different
than what it is now so just have that as
in
bro you just got slapped in your face
you know what adam did you came to adam
with a shock effect
do you know your religion and anita
muhammad hijab
and imran they believe that
you should have capital punishment
apostates
and use one adam to be like no really
adam is taking the mick out of you this
is a part of our religion there's a
reason to it
yeah there's a reason why there's a
capital punishment because people like
you little weaklings
who leave their religion and cause
corruption in the land by spreading it
the capital punishment and islamic law
will be applied to you we have no doubt
and we're proud of that
yeah not individuals going and doing it
themselves like
idiots yeah no under an emir it is done
yes and we you know what we'll be
watching we'll be watching
because if you're going to cause
corruption in the land that's going to
cause
more damage to the society as a whole
because the sharia didn't come to
protect an individual's right hey can i
drink okay
sure drink alcohol run someone over kill
them say
all this kind of chaos no islam says the
right of the community
is greater than you individual wanting
your right to freedom which is
bs absolutely bs yeah don't get me
started so he just backfired on you
let's see what happens now open mind
this is not an allegation that i make
this is something that each one of them
has confirmed in one way or another
before i'm not sure if tawa man has ever
said that publicly but i am very sure
that if you ask him
and if he's not shy from expressing his
beliefs publicly then he will confirm
this
and if you don't want to ask him i would
ask him it is simply a fact that i am
stating
because it looks like this is something
that should normally bother you
and many people who watch you adam i
don't blame you if i was ever to listen
to this guy i'll be listening to it when
i'm in the toilet
in the toilet toilet yeah like i've got
a bad stomach yeah
that's when i'll be listening so i'm i'm
happy that you're having the time to you
know give yourself some nutrition
because i would not waste my time with
this guy
yeah he got rich he got destroyed by
daniel hakika he had a debate
he got destroyed baba farid exposed him
so badly this guy has no idea about
islam
but that you have simply not properly
thought through because these
voices and concerns haven't reached you
and to be honest religion is quite
boring i would love to
the religion is quite boring what is
this a game is supposed to be like which
one is more fun
okay that's more fun you believe in
eight gods because if you make a mistake
here you can go to the other guy
adam destroyed you buff adam adam
absolutely rinsed you out
you was trying to come with the shock
effect adam was like he's so right for
you brother he was like
oh so religious is supposed to be fun
and this is why you're a weakling this
is why people like you are weaklings
who leave islam why because oh i don't
like that
oh that's so hard brother if you believe
in something to be the truth
you will follow it not ah i can't follow
this religion man why
you know fasting it's too hard
probably i know some little kids that do
it just because you're a weakling little
puss boy yeah little weak one
don't project yourself around everyone
else
add them so right for you broth
i'm just losing brain cells man city's
not a good day i'm losing too many brain
cells since you said you would like to
talk to ex-muslims i would love to
accept your invitation i would love to
have a conversation with you or you
could join me
and have a conversation with me you may
not consider yourself the best person to
talk about religious matters which is
also completely okay by the way but you
know what i think and i would even
travel and visit you for that
i think it would be amazing if i could
come together with you and alidawah for
example and i could simply ask alidawah
about his beliefs
and he could ask me about mine we could
talk to each other you can tell us what
you think you can share your beliefs we
don't need to fight
all that we need is to sit together and
have an honest exchange of opinions
and ideas beliefs and feelings people
would love to see that happen
you can then observe what alidawah
really believes in what he himself says
and decide whether you like it or not
and i assure you there will be a lot of
surprises for you in that
and also in everything that i believe i
mean if you're talking about learning
about islam and coming closer to islam
i'm not i can't be learning from you
when you just said and the religion is
kind of boring
well adam sees right through you adam is
destroying you adam is
rinsing you out broth that guy is
rinsing i'm so sorry the guy
just rinsed your arguments he was
looking for a shock effect the guy is
laughing he's having conflicts he's
having about where's the yoga but he's
not having yoga
mama's having yoga yeah brother you're
getting so rinsed out
it's not working but we're going to come
to that challenge you just said
oh bad it's early in the morning man
seriously i was getting my seriously
i'll just get a video
aren't we both doing basically the same
thing on opposite sides
after that the fact that he has the
obligation to propagate islam to you and
to others whereas i don't have any
obligation at
all to tell people to stay away from
islam but i definitely have the will i
would be positively surprised and very
happy if alidawah
accepted such an offer and would want
this conversation to happen
your own audience and so many other
people around the world would want to
see this conversation
people would watch it with excitement it
is something that hasn't happened before
and even if people only watch it because
they want islam to win
and they want me an ex-muslim an
opponent of islam to be disproved and
destroyed
islam always wins at the end of the day
and no no one wants you to be destroyed
you seem like you're already destroyed
since you're away from islam like you're
in
well like that's true that's true you're
already destroyed by the way adam if you
don't know this is somebody
who has some kind of like problems that
he was at a traffic light once yes yes
he himself testified to this
and because the light wasn't going green
he said he was nearly going to run over
an innocent woman or something like that
he wanted to run in over innocent people
his friend david wood smashed his dad's
head in
his own father's head in and by the way
this is the very same guy i asked him
if he would commit incest have
intercourse with his own son
or daughter yeah and his only argument
was he accepted it his only argument was
oh but it will cause harm i said no if
there's no harm if you use contraceptive
would you do it this filthy dirty boy
that would have hold intercourse with
his son and his daughter is going to
come and tell us about islam
but you get rinsed but let's carry on
wouldn't it done the challenge is coming
boy
wrong path buddy and i really really
really feel like you could be going
the right path if you just stop being a
little weenie man
thank you you are a little weenie buff
you're a phony
you're a phony yes bob you're a phony
i'm gonna speak your language yeah
you are a phony cause you know why
you're a phony a puss
you know why because you're weaker even
i'm sorry
there was a word yeah okay look at the
weenie but what the hell is this
what's this guy crying what the hell is
this
what the hell is this even adam sees
through you the religion's kind of
boring like the fact that you were
muslim before now you're saying that
like what were you looking for like i'm
looking for some spice in my life
it's you know it's subhanallah man it's
seriously it scares me and i
accept i accept you to be on socially
profiled with adam saleh and slim back
and i will ask alidawah and mohammed
hijab if they are down to also be in
this podcast episode and we are down to
talk to you and to give you some dawah
because a lot of people were messaging
me telling me that this guy whatever his
name is something prophet i don't know
why the heck he's
calling himself a prophet like you just
lost it bro you've gone some different
type of path man i don't know where
you've gone out but you're really really
far but it's okay i'll be there slim
will beat him
will be there and you will be there
muhammad agree we will like you win not
this tuesday but the next tuesday
afternoon because we are definitely
always ready ali
is always in london at the speaker's
corner shutting people up like you
muhammad hijab is always in debate
exposing people like you i'm excited to
see how it goes i hope you guys are
too do me a game guys here's the
challenge
he said he will travel anywhere yeah the
boy little boy what do they say travel
anywhere okay no problem
i will pay for your ticket me me me me
me
i'm gonna find a way i'm gonna pay your
ticket no bro come to london
come to london london london speakers
corner face to face like a man
not behind a computer i want to look at
you in the eyes
yeah i'm not going to get mohammed you
have to come because you said that you
might crap your pants
yeah you might defecate yeah you could
say to yourself yeah
i'm going to make sure he's not there
because i don't want you to have a heart
attack and then you start you know going
to the madden and then say
islam it surely did this to me yeah we
will pay for your ticket
you come to speaker's corner yeah like a
man come
yeah come and we're going to debate you
there come yeah
the only reason you're doing this is
because and why we would not agree
to do it on the podcast is because we
know you're an attention seeker
we know you've got the show about daniel
mohammadi i've even asked you for
informal
debate discussion yeah do you have no
credentials you're no one
you've got destroyed by for read left
right center so we know you're only
doing this to get
attention and we're not gonna let that
no if you want it you're gonna come we
will pay for your ticket you come to
london
you come to london and we will have a
debate is islam
the truth yeah is islam the truth if you
disprove we'll join you
no problem will join me that's what's
going to happen inshallah brothers and
sisters
and until next time assalamu alaikum
weak ones little ones like yourself
apus